-With Donald Trump's
presidential reelection campaign
suing to stop Michigan
and Pennsylvania's
ballot counts,
he is asking his supporters
to take action.
Here, to talk about it,
is Trump supporter
and rapper Lil Doof.
[ Mellow hip hop plays ]
-Yeah.
It's your man Lil Doof.
And you know
what I always say.
Anyone who makes me pay a lot
of taxes can't have my vote.
♪ It's like I ♪
-Whoa, whoa. Sorry, wait, uh --
-What?
-It's just, um, sorry,
but, you, uh,
you always say that?
-Yeah.
Yeah, I always say that.
I'm like -- I'm always talking
about that, yeah.
-Oh.
Okay. Sorry.
Go ahead.
♪♪
-Yeah.
It's your boy Lil Doof.
Coming straight atcha.
America First Records
taking over.
Come on. Let's go.
♪ It's like I ♪
-Sorry.
-What?
-Sorry to interrupt.
Did you say
America First Records?
-Yeah.
I'm part of the AF squad.
-Oh.
So that's a record label
that's...
-Owned and operated
by Donald Trump.
-Yeah.
You heard of it?
-No.
I just assumed
because of the name.
-Oh. Okay.
I thought maybe
you were like a fan --
-No.
-Alright.
Alright.
Okay.
Uh, let's bring that track back.
♪♪
Unh, yeah.
It's your boy Lil Doof.
America First Records.
Come on, now.
♪ When I say, "Stop" ♪
♪ You say, "The vote" ♪
♪ Stop ♪
Hey.
-It's just, um,
no one's here, so,
no one's going to answer you.
-Wait, not even these guys
are going to like...?
-No, no one here
is going to do that.
-Okay.
[ Crying ]
I don't even need
them like that.
-Oh, oh, Lil -- Lil Doof.
Lil Doof, are --
are you alright?
-Being a rapper is hard,
you know?
-No, I do not know.
-I don't even want
to be doing this.
I thought this would be easy.
Trump told me he needed a rapper
to endorse him
to get the Black vote
and that, if I did that, he'd
give me a buttload of money.
-Aw. Oh, my God.
That's terrible.
I'm so sorry.
-I told him that I was not
a good rapper
and that was not a good
way to get the Black vote
and that I am not musical,
in any way, but he insisted.
He even wrote all my rhymes.
-Oh, man.
Trump wrote your rhymes?
-Yeah. You'd have been able
to figure that out
because, later in the song,
I rhyme Mitch McConnell
with Rosie O'Donnell.
-Aw. That's a shame.
I bet he even
made you change your name
to Lil Doof?
-No, it's Lil Doof.
Of the Pennsylvania Doofs.
-Oh!
I will have to
take your word on that.
Look, you don't have
to keep supporting Trump,
if you don't want to.
-I don't?
-No!
Lil Doof, you're your own man.
-Oh. Thanks, Seth.
Hey, you know what?
I'd like to take
this opportunity
to officially retire
from the rap game.
And, hey, Seth.
-Yeah, Lil Doof?
-♪ You know what they say ♪
-Yeah, I'm going
to need you to leave.
I'm going to need you
to go now.
-Yeah, sure.
I understand that.
-Lil Doof, everybody!
We'll be right back
with Demi Lovato.